c-block 1-ий концерт фонду боротьби з
такими і їм виручка гілку від Києва
прохідка приблизно 46 тисяч гривень
буде прямого на треба допоможуть їм кому
потрібно трансплантата кіст кого мозок
ненависть і з брат граючи
віджиму русі та гранту я безкоштовно
доступ до тріумфу раку де буде кого
російської громади на
[музика]
процедур вона дійсно безкоштовно
але трансплантація сама процедура тут
на вас кущів на олексій ви витратите з
кішок у донора ляховича плащі пацієнта та
все донора знати і на російській
реєстрі за кішкою вишку 300 тисяч рублів
рахунок за кордон йому
та мета , мільйони у російському реєстрі
душа мало донорі на всю росію
у нас є купа з 10 тисяч донорі одягнений
не матч і не чисть мільйоні 60000
доларів тоді як на маленьку Німеччину
6 мільйонів шукати вручені вище хвороби
навички meola і багатих кому потрібно
дорога хіміотерапія ланка законом хвороби
за неї три молоді і препарати піску
стоуном Аліна ритку геть з такої в тебе
вартість докази просто на моєму їх на
закупив і ось нас причина суть низ
координації між обласними
департаментами їх шкоди та здоров'я the
unholy корінням федерально накопичує порядку
ванням ін ша ці kurupt нададуть експерти
одну з тіньових схем ще давно виявили з
turo-bit.net ще 10 другу та московську
liqueur їм як поважайте дні весни
крачок в Росії якщо кого не чи raccoon
корінням алла автономний статус з
окупована препарати прямо через
департаментах шкоди та здоров'ям виявилося
шукайте no notice америці видозмінюється
брухт каразим у лові корейців та висновок
разу дзвенів чи корінням витрачав
автономний статус
civic locallow буринь а пацієнта в та
чи інших карего ви його лось ще проблем
вона багата шурхіт за конфлікт у крему
взятому ми дачному закланню почалося з
того з епохи лося стільця, що ми просто
вийшли на захотіли карені та вікі нам у
відвали життя
а новина проблема вже пройшла вінса
товщину навесні а проблема
централізовано закупилася вона
дозволяє грамотно керувати фінансами
is nigh проблема корупційних смартфона
змов минулого року було закуплено
один із він капрі тарик 60 чи друга
карнизу купив один зон корпоратив з
ризниці юцинеле корені куб елади, що йшла
води нацією відбивши води носити лише
департамент охорони здоров'я ніж
департамент охорони здоров'я це
незаконно закупили асфальту ціни за
купив для гранітні щурів ти сцени б
чудових ствол-то шпага ну
алимова і d прожите смерть людей і
виявляють все-таки драматичніші цифри
романтичні цифри так чаїнок шабель і
суттєво ви страждали часткою брати
на себе благо денікін дати ачий фонд
дорозі жити а втомимося часом порушуючи
виділяючи адресу на допомогу
і але діви ще на багате факти
миші за місцями ще піде і але на
тріумфування москву parable 1toy місці волі
корінням так-то фактичного викинуто
роботу держави як прихід людина до
приходять люди миня і місяців і в nova
3 мій видно вазу всіх клінік даний
моїми ск про них з правдиним a і c на вигляд
б ска причому самі йшли до і ви знаєте
чого не могли провести високу зручність
мають арапії у собі про світом у
хабаровську і був у них бог прилла для
монітора ну концентрації лікарських
препаратів у крові до за civic ми купила
12 приладнавши еасп одягаюся ще іншу
терапію доступ невже терапії доступна
за даними міністерства охорони здоров'я
рфс чирок а в Росії виявляють magic
500000 випадки банку за хвороби він близько
половина з них на 3 чверті стадії
близько 300 тисяч хворих допомагає проти
вам тіньків рокки в піснях встановлений
ідеал
[музика]